Olivier no on va commencer avec vous
bonjour merci de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu du Nord membre du groupe Union
centriste vis président de la commission
des affaires sociales et corapporteur du
budget de la SCU dont on va parler dans
quelques instants mais d'abord on l'a vu
dans le journal Distel juive ont été
dégradés retrouvé dégradé dans un
cimetière militaire allemand dans lois
hier Gérald aRM a dit que plus de 1700
événements antisémites ont eu lieu
depuis le 7 octobre comment on répond à
ces actes quelle suite on donne à la
marge de dimanche
alors on est confronté à un
antisémitisme et une haine du Juif hein
parlons concrètement auquel on éétait
pas habitué au fond on s'attendait pas à
une telle à une telle violence je pense
que là
vraiment c'est le le le rôle de de
l'éducation le rôle aussi des des écoles
des lycées vous voyez le réhabiliter par
exemple le métier de de de de profs
d'enseignants je pense que c'est c'est
notre société qui doit revoir ses ses
codes et et et faire en sorte partout de
de de lutter contre
l'antisémitisme voilà on est confronté à
une nouvelle forme
d'antisémitisme c'est plus le
l'antisémitisme morcien d'autrefois
c'est celui qu'on voit naître aussi dans
les banlieux enfin je vais pas mendre
sur le sujet parce qu'il est dramatique
d'ailleurs pour notre société mais vous
dites comme Bruno retaillon on n'est pas
dans une résurgence de l'antisémitisme
on est dans un nouveau terreau celui de
l'islamisme politique ah c'est clair oui
oui oui c'est pas le c'est pas du du
tout l'antisémitisme de Moras pour être
précis sur le plan intellectuel non
c'est une c'est un
antisémitisme quasi CIV
civilisationnel de la civilisation hein
c'est c'est c'est c'est pas le même
qu'autre foois non c'est c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on est en quelque
sorte démuni parce
que moi dans ma prime jeunesse j'étais
on était militant de de de de
l'antiracisme de de mais on voit bien
que c'est pas ça la question là c'est
une autre question c'est une question de
civilisation hein et donc je pense que
c'est quand même à l'école au collège au
lycée les leçons d'instruction civique
faut remettre l'ouvrage sur le métier
notamment par rapport aux réseaux
sociaux parce que c'est aussi beaucoup
dans les réseaux sociaux que tout ça se
développe hein c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est pas dans les cultes c'est non
c'est les réseaux sociaux ce sont les
réseaux sociaux l'autre actualité on l'a
également vu dans le journal ce sont ces
inondations ellisabeth borne est dans le
P decalis ce matin mais votre
département du Nord a également été
touché l'état de catastrophe naturelle
décrété dans une trentaine de communes
quelle est la la situation dans votre
département aujourd'hui ah la situation
alors elle est encore beaucoup plus
grave dans le P de calis mais il y a
aussi le le le le le Nord j'entendais
Christophe Béchu voyez c'est toujours ça
qui est terrible c'est que on a le
sentiment que on gère toujours
l'urgence ce qui arrive
alors à cette ampleur peut-être pas mais
beaucoup de gens nous le disaient voyez
on est dans une dans une région dans des
départements où c'est les wateringues
c'est les moines qui ont souvent gagné
du terrain sur la mer on est quelquefois
en dessous de du niveau de la mer on a
mal entretenu les les les les les
rivières les fossées il y a les stations
de relevage des eau qui fonctionnent pas
forcément qu'est-ce que vous voulez il
faut à ce moment-là à la fois ger
l'urgence avec le plan de solidarité
nationale mais aussi qui a la hauteur
juste ce plan 50 millions pour les
collectivités 80 millions pour les
agriculteurs c'est avec Xavier Bertrand
je crois que la la région il travaille
je pense que oui la question c'est c'est
que l'État soit au rendez-vous et que
l'Europe aussi he ça a été dit hier
voilà mais je pense que la question de
l'urgence le fonctionnement de l'urgence
généralement ça va mais pour vous il g
l'urgence Christophe parce que lui ce
qu' vous a dit hier au Sénat c'est que
s'il avait été capable de transmettre
rapidement ce ce texte sur la la
simplification du curage des rivières
c'est parce qu'il y avait travaillé en
amont et parce que il s était pas pris
la dernière minute c'est parce que c'est
un texte déjà travaillé c'est pas
tellement lui que je mets en cause hein
c'est le fonctionnement de l'État
souvent trop technocratique c'est que
peut-être ça a été anticipé mais à ce
moment-là 1 2 3 ans mais pas 10 ans moi
moi je prends l'exemple de ce qui se
passe au Pays-Bas au au au Pays-Bas à la
fois il y a un entretien à la fois aussi
il faut prévenir le changement
climatique euh le fonctionnement des
Diges de nouvelles digues tout ça parce
qu' ce qui se passe c'est à la fois la
pluie et à la fois la mer qui monte en
quelque sorte donc il y a un double
phénomène qui explique ces inondations
je je je je crains peut-être pas cette
ampleur mais que si on n'a pas des une
vision à long terme avec un un nouveau
fonctionnement par rapport aux EAU au
dig pas seulement d'entretien mais aussi
quelque chose qui prend en compte ce
changement climatique on est appelé à
reconnaître ce genre de situation donc
il y a l'urgence il y a l'entretien et
puis il y a la vision de l'avenir et la
préparation de l'avenir on va revenir
sur l'actualité du Nord ce sera dans
quelques instants avec W votre
télévision locale mais d'abord on va
parler de l'actualité du Sénat les
sénateurs qui poursuivent l'examen du
budget de la Sécurité sociale dont vous
êtes le corapporteur Olivier on va faire
le point sur ces dernières heures de
séance avec Mathias
[Musique]
Araz bonjour Mathias bonjour bonjour
Olivier bonjour et Mathias vous avez
suivi la séance d'hier soir sur ce
budget de la Sécurité sociale les
sénateurs ont bien avancé ou on touche
enfin à des articles grand public Oran
après tous les volets concernant les
équilibres financiers les sénateurs ont
débattu et adopté plusieurs séries
d'amendements très concret par exemple
Lian cet amendement des sénateurs
Renaissance concernant le remboursement
par les employeurs des abonnements au
servicees de location de vélo par des
opérateurs privés jusqu'ici les
obligations concernaient pour les
entreprises ell ne concernaient que les
opérateurs publics dans la même veine le
Sénat a adopté une mesure pour
pérenniser l'incitation en faveur d'une
prise en charge à 75 % de l'abonnement
au transport public la mesure avait été
instaurée en 2022 et pour une durée
limitée grâce à un amendement du
républicain philippe Tabarot spécialiste
des questions mobilité elle pourrait
être gravée dans le marbre autre débat
qui a eu lieu hier soir Mathias celui
sur les taxes comportte Monal oui et en
premier lieu celle sur l'alcool voilà de
quoi il était notamment question hier
Orian c'est un marogier chaque année
lors de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale vous
l'avez dit cette taxe comportementale
d'un côté ce qui défendent le fait qu'il
faut les relever pour augmenter leur
contribution au budget de la Sécurité
sociale c'est notamment le cas de la
sénatrice de meurthmoiselle Véronique
Guillotin concernant les taxes
comportementales on peut tout dire mais
on a quand même vu que les taxes
concernant le tabac en fait
l'augmentation du coût du coût du tabac
a bien entraîné le le le le la baisse de
la consommation de tabac cela incitera
encore les français via effectivement le
porte-monnaie à réduire la consommation
en tout cas c'est juste l'objectif de
cet amendement ben problème pour le
gouvernement comme pour une partie la
majorité même de l'hémicycle ce n'est
pas la bonne solution cessons de penser
qu'il aurait comme un remède miracle à
travers le levier fiscal qui nous évite
le vrai débat sur la politique
préventive donc je veux dire moi je suis
pas favorable à l'augmentation de la
taxe d'alcool d'abord je l'ai dit parce
que je pense que ça ne peut pas se
substituer une politique de prévention
et d'autre part ce serait un mauvais
coup portter à une filière qui est par
ailleurs en difficulté que la plupart
d'entre vous avaient souhaité soutenir
dans les débats précédents donc c'est un
avis défavorable sur l'alcool ça ne
passe pas Olivier a vous aviez justement
un amendement qui allait dans ce sens il
a été rejeté est-ce que vous le
regrettez je je je pense que la question
elle est quand même beaucoup plus large
hein c'est la question de notre
politique de prévention la question par
rapport à la la malbouffe la question
par rapport à l'alcool la question par
rapport à la consommation de tabac qui
malheureusement reprogresse chez les
jeunes il y a quand même dans notre
fonctionnement national une vraie
difficulté voyez sur le tabac c'est qu'à
la fois euh on lutte pour la prévention
et à la fois ça vient abonder le le
budget de la de la sécurité sociale
alors je il me semble que plus
globalement si vous voulez il va falloir
un moment comme ça a été fait dans
d'autres pays sortir de cette ambiguité
c'est-à-dire est-ce que on est vraiment
dans une politique de prévention et à ce
moment-là la taxation elle doit être
brutale je pense au tabac les pays qui
ont éradiqué parce que voyez on parle de
50000 morts par an hein quand on parle
du de l'alcool je veux dire c'est à peu
près ce qu'on a eu pour le covid hein il
faut faut voir le l'ampleur du du du du
phénomène et et idem pour la malbouffe
le sport la prévention et donc la
question c'est les pays qui ont réussi
par exemple sur le tabac c'est ceux qui
ont à un moment donné dit bon ben voilà
le le le prix
du du du du paquet de cigarettes c'est
30 € mais c'est pas en augmentant un ou
deux et et bien évidemment ça doit être
pris à l'échelle européenne donc ce sont
des débats qui à mon avis ne sont pas
les débats fondamentaux du PLFSS qui est
plutôt celui des grands équilibre et de
du fait que on finance pas nos dépenses
de santé à l'échelle de 9 milliards
aujourd'hui et de 17 milliards dans 3
ans la grande question quand même du
spfss elle est là et et et on a une
surconsommation médicale et des
indicateurs de de santé qui sont
préoccupants on va on va y venir à ces
grands équilibres mais il y a quand même
d'autres sujets qui intéressent les
Français qui ont été abordés hier alors
sur l'alcool c'est pas passé on l'a vu
sur le sucre en revanche c'est passé oui
il y a eu des amendements notamment
portés par le sénateur des hautes scènes
Xavier yacovelli une proposition adoptée
qui vise à réformer la taxe soda elle a
été mise en place en en 2018 on s'en
souvient avec cet amendement adopté
contre l'avis du gouvernement c'est à
noter une boisson qui contient entre 50
et 80 g de sucre par litre se verrait
donc appliquer une taxe de 20 21
centimes soit environ le triple du
montant actuel de la taxe cette somme
elle pourrait même monter jusqu'à 28
centimes pour les sodas les plus sucrés
par la suite les sénateurs ont également
adopté un autre amendement là aussi
contre l'avis du gouvernement il était
présenté par le LR François bonhomme il
vise à taxer les produits alimentaires
trop transformés et contenant des sucres
ajoutés en fonction de leur quantité on
sait que les aut hein les additifs de
toutes sortes sont à l'origine de
maladiie chronique avec des vraiment des
complications sévères ça vous nuit à
votre santé à votre confort de vie et
vous nous dites on va s'en prendre au
pouvoir d'achat mais on s'en prend au
pouvoir de vivre là mais c'est quand
même incroyable cet argument il ne tient
pas monsieur le ministre vous avez
commencé un petit peu à y répondre à y
répondre Olivier pourquoi une telle
frilosité à l'heure de taxer plus des
produits dont la dangerosité ben elle
est établie ah là j'avoue que je
comprends pas moi je je je je suis même
plus radical c'està-dire que si on euh
si si à un moment donné un produit est
dangereux par exemple j'entends dire que
il y a de plus en plus de sucre dans les
petits pots pour bébé euh bon bah si les
industriels sont irresponsables à ce
moment-là fixons des normes mais alors
là très strictes ou des produits trop
sucrés serait interdit à la vente parce
que la fiscalité bon voilà on va
augmenter un peu le prix mais ça c'est
limite moi je pense vraiment s'il s'agit
de de de de de question de santé dans
les plats préparés dans les boissons de
soda dans les petits pot pour bébé et
bien fixons des normes et interdisons ce
genre de produit à la vente je je ne
vois pas pourquoi on n'est pas plus
offensif vis-à-vis parce que là on parle
pas des petits artisans ou de de de de
gens qui préparent dans les boutiques
hein c'est c'est le système
agroalimentaire et et notamment
industriel qu'il faut encadrer avec des
normes beaucoup plus strictes puisque
visiblement il y a des de plus en plus
de de problèmes en terme de santé
publique sur ces questions j'ai une
dernière question Olivier Le le le Sénat
a rejeté hier comme l'an dernier la
trajectoire du financement de la
sécurité sociale pour les quatre
prochaines années c'est un vote
symbolique on le sait mais le message
derrière quel est-il bah c'est c'est que
ouis on sera jugé sévèrement moi là je
le dis avec gravité autant on peut
s'endetter pour construire des
infrastructures je parlais des dig tout
à l'heure dans notre région par rapport
aux innovations bien sûr aux inondations
et avoir des innovation aussi dans
beaucoup de domaines mais mais là on
paye pas nos nos nos notre système de de
protection sociale et on va le faire
payer par les générations à venir mais
quelle irresponsabilité alors c'est
contre ça qu'on qu'on proteste et
pourquoi on en est là parce qu'il y a
pas de réforme structurelle et si vous
ne faites pas de réforme structurelle
vous finissez par dépenser beaucoup
d'argent pour une surconsommation
médicale des indicateurs de santé qui ne
sont plus bons vous appliquez la
politique du rabot c'est ce qui est fait
et finalement bah vous gérez une forme
de pinuerie et ben on y est et donc on
peut pas reporter s'endetter d'autant
plus qu'on est dans un nouveau monde le
monde où avant on s'endetttait pour pas
cher pour même avec des taux d'intérêt
négatif c'est fini ça on s'endettete
maintenant pour beaucoup plus cher et
donc il y a une forme d'irresponsabilité
et c'est avec gravité que nous au groupe
UC d'ailleurs on on on dénonce cette
question on peut pas s'endetter sur des
de de ce qui relève de notre vie courant
et notre fonctionnement et reporter ça
sur les générations à venir c'est
totalement irresponsable le message vous
l'avez fait passer est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'il sera entendu par le
gouvernement bah on on a l'impression
qu'ils savent pas s'y prendre on a
l'impression évidemment que les réformes
structurelles elles vont demander du
courage sur la surconsommation médicale
sur le le peut-être même la question de
la liberté de l'installation la question
de du libre choix du médecin enfin tout
ça posons-le mais on peut pas DP être un
des pays qui dépensons le plus autrefois
on était fier de notre système de
protection sociale et de maladie
aujourd'hui on voit bien que ça s'est
léardé ça s'est affessé le problème de
l'hôpital donc on continue à dépenser
beaucoup on surconsomme et finalement on
a une santé qui se dégrade on peut pas
continuer comme ça donc évidemment ça va
être douloureux les les les les les les
réformes structurelles elles sont
complexes mais c'est ça la
responsabilité politique il faut aborder
toutes ces questions parce que sans ça
on va avoir une trajectoire et à un
moment on va dire ben voilà on a plus
les moyens et qui est-ce qui va qui
est-ce qui va payer la note et ben ce
sont les plus fragil et les plus faibles
si si on n'est pas capable de faire ces
réformes structurelles et il y a urgence
sur ces réformes structurelles notamment
en matière de santé vous êtes le
rapporteur de la branche famille vous de
ce budget de la Sécurité sociale vous
dites que la politique familiale c'est
la grande oubli comment vous l'expliquez
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement alors on a avec Aurore
berger il semble qu'il y a une volonté
hein donc bon après ce sont des discours
on verra les actes c'est comm en amour
c'est les preuv d'amour qui compte he
bon mais voyez je je je je suis très
étonné moi toujours par ça on est tombé
de 850000 naissances à 700000 naissances
alors certains nous disent comme Madame
Rossignol hein oui mais la politique
familiale elle a pas d'influence sur la
natalité finalement c'est pas les
allocations familiales mais enfin c'est
un domaine elles ne sont plus
universelles les allocations familiales
vous avez des
revenus vous vous n'avez plus plus plus
les aides que vous aviez auparavant ça
c'est le gouvernement Hollande qui a
pris cette funeste décision il y a pas
la la réforme du congé parental on a dit
de fois 2 ans plutôt qu'une fois 3 ans
là aussi le gouvernement Holland ça
marche pas il y a plus personne qui le
prend sur le le le les les les aides
pour les gardes d'enfants bah il y a pas
de tier payant ah bah oui mais tout
compé si vous regardez le moment où vous
décidez d'avoir un enfant et les jeunes
couple ou les couples et bien ça c'est
c'est sans doute là que la société elle
vous accompagne le moins c'est-à-dire
que un couple qui décide d'avoir un
enfant voit son niveau de vie baisser
fortement la question du logement et
cetera et il faut pas s'étonner
c'est comme si on avait décidé à un
moment sur la branche maladie de dire
bah vous avez des certains revenus on va
plus vous aider on va plus vous
rembourser pour la maladie et ben c'est
ce qui se passe pour la branche famille
on fait rien ou très peu donc d'où la
grande oubliée on consomme même pas le
budget on est toujours excédentaire et
on s'étonne que la natalité baisse or il
faudrait là je un véritable plan Marchal
c'est un mot évidemment qu'on utilise
beaucoup mais une décision très forte
notamment sur les modes de garde parce
que voyez il y a aussi on annonce des
des créations de crèchees mais en
réalité il y a des crèches qui ferment
parce que le métier n'est plus
suffisamment attractif c'est ça la
réalité aujourd'hui c'est très difficile
pour des couples de décider d'avoir un
enfant et donc il faut pas et je étonné
de ce qui se passe et je suis très
étonné qu'on qu'on s'en par pas plus
vigoureusement cette question très grave
grave pour la société et grave même pour
notre financement de de retraite de
système de protection sociale demain
merci Mathias à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure on parlera inondation et état de
catastrophe naturelle ce sera à suivre
dans le club on revient à l'actualité
dans votre département Olivier on va à
Lille où on retrouve pierre-Jérôme
montenau bonjour pierre-Jérôme merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous rédacteur en
chef de W c'est la télévision locale
pierre Jérôme voulez revenir vous sur la
suppression de l'Ame l'aide médicale
d'État qui a été votée par le Sénat dans
le projet de lo immigration
oui bonjour à tous bonjour Olivier cette
suppression elle est très testé par les
ONG qui s'occupent des populations en
difficulté notamment des étrangers avec
deux axes il dénonce une menace pour la
santé publique et puis un coût puisque
les personnes si elles sont soignées
plus tard vont coûter plus cher en
examen en lit
d'hospitalisation et cetera et d'autre
part ell risque si elles ne sont pas
soignées de contaminer la population
est-ce que là on n'est pas en train euh
pour faire de l'affichage politique de
de se tirer une balle dans le pied alors
moi je l'ai voté je je ne peux pas dire
que j'ai pas longuement réfléchi mais
d'abord il y a pas rienin il y a une une
aide médicale d'urgence donc les gens
qui vont devoir être soignés vont
continuer à être soignés mais on a
cherché une forme d'équilibre entre
soigner les personnes qui sont malades
et qui viennent d'arriver par exemple
bon et et aussi le le signal qu'on
envoie parce
que la question de l'immigration et
notamment du du choc démographique avec
l'Afrique subsaharienne n'est pas une
question qu'on peut évacuer comme ça
donc ça envoie un signal de dire que bah
la France n'est pas l'endroit où on peut
se faire soigner gratuitement si on
vient d'arriver ça ne remet pas en cause
le droit d'asile ça ne remet pas en
cause non plus le le le fait après de de
pouvoir soigner les gens qui sont
malades l'aide médicale d'urgence va
permettre hein je je le dis c'est après
voyez la question c'est le panier de
soins mais on a trouvé un équilibre
entre soigner les gens qui vont être
malades parce que ils vont être soignés
faut pas faut pas raconter d'histoire
vous imaginez les médecins qui
diraientent bah non on va pas soigner
les gens d'ailleurs on verra lors du
budget il y aur question c'est les soins
tardif la question c'est les soins
tardifs et les soins plus coûteux c'est
là qui mettent le qui mettent le doigt
les soignants bah je pense qu'on verra à
l'usage mais mais mais mais il faut pas
faire croire qu'il y aura rien il y a
une une aide médicale d'urgence donc les
gens qui vont être malades par exemple
pour des maladies qui pourraent être
contagieuses ou des maladies chroniques
vont naturellement pouvoir être soigné
mais la France n'est pas ou n'est plus
l'Eldorado où on arrive et puis on est
soigné gratuitement parce que nous
étions les seuls à faire ça et donc il
faut pas faut faut dire les choses on
envoie un signal parce que savez ave que
les réseaux sociaux et cetera ça se
propage dans un dans un certain nombre
d'endroits que l'immigration irrégulière
et l'immigration économique n'est pas la
bienvenue dans notre pays et donc à
travers un certain nombre de symboles
faut pas se le cacher c'est c'est c'est
c'est ça que c'est c'est pas une
question financière c'est pas une
question de de de de morale c'est une
question d'envoyer un signal mais en
même temps vous verrez enfin moi je je
je je ou alors on mettra l'ouvrage sur
le métier avec l'aide médicale d'urgence
on soignera les gens qui sont malades
qu'ils soient français ou qu'il ne le
soit pas pierregér vous avez pardon ah
non vous avez une autre question
là-dessus une dernière après on passe au
sénatorial non allez-y oui je voulais
passer sur les sénatoriales dans le Nord
on a vu lors des dernières élections la
multiplication des listes centriste y
compris dans votre propre
formation tout le monde c'est Roby
Becher aujourd'hui vous vous siégez tous
dans le même groupe quelle est le quelle
est l'ambiance postélectorale et
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a eu cette
multiplication
c'est une question complexe vous savez
les partis sont moins structurés ils
sont moins organisés que que que
qu'autrefois les la la la
diversité il y a aussi beaucoup plus de
gens qui se sont divers droite et non
inscrit et donc on n plus dans le même
monde moi quand j'ai adhéré alors ça va
pas me rajeunir de dire ça j'ai j'ai
j'étais avec André diligeent il y avait
deux listes sénatoriales voyez il y en a
eu 16 donc c'est pas du tout la la la
même chose après les relations
personnelles euh les les campagnes c'est
c'est une chose mais après on a une
responsabilité vis-à-vis de de l'UDI
vis-à-vis du groupe usé et on fait en
sorte que cette institution elle soit
préservée et qu'elle ne se voit pas
victime de nos chocs personnels ou nos
sentiments finalement peu importe
l'affecte là-dedans l'essentiel c'est de
défendre l'intérêt général le bien
commun et nos convictions au travers de
de du groupe UC et de l'UDI he voilà
c'est ça l'important le groupe Jen quoi
c'est ce que vous n dites group Grou vit
bien le groupe vit bien voilà exactement
c'est essentiel merci merci Pierre
Jérôme montenau merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous rédacteur en chef de wo
c'est la télévision locale notamment
dans le Nord merci beaucoup pierre-
Jérôme un mot sur les rencontres de
Saint- qui auront lieu demain c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui convie les chefs de
parti à Saint-Denis épisode 2 vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'UDI vous l'UD
ira RV Marseilla mais pas les LR est-ce
que vous le regrettez ah ben moi en
règle générale je ne suis jamais
partisan de la chaise vide alors j'ai
même quelquefois rigolé en théorisant le
le principe de la chaise pleine mais le
principe même de la de de de la
politique de c'est la discussion alors à
la sortie rien n'empêche de critiquer
mais enfin quand même si dans un pays
qui qui qui est aussi fracturé que la
France avec toutes les crises qu'on
connaît les partis dit de gouvernement
républicains ne peuvent pas discuter
avec le président de la République bah
s'il y a de la com bah si on y va
faisons aussi de la com si j'ose dire
c'est dire on peut faire rien n'empêche
mais mais c'est une faute politique
majeure comme le dit Emmanuel Macron
alors je je je vais pas taxer ça j'ai
pas de jugement là-dessus j'aime pas ce
genre de jugement mais en tous les cas
moi je dire nous on a eu un débat et
j'ai plutôt encouragé après il était
libre évidemment de de décider mais
Hervé Marseille d'y aller enfin moi je
crois que c'est le rôle des partis de
gouvernement de dire discuter avec le
président de la République et le
gouvernement enfin c'est le rôle du
Parlement et d'ailleurs Gérard Larcher
il va c'est tout à fait naturel merci
Olivier merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité